Good morning Hank. It's Monday.
This week we're gonna be learning about the
mating habits of -oh come on. Don't do that
in front of the children.
Okay Hank so, tortoises are majestic reptiles.
They can live to be more than 200 years old.
[tortoise in coitus in background which sounds
vaguely like a distorted recording of a cat
being thrown into a blender] What is that
noise? [tortoise in coitus] Really, that's
an actual recording of a tortoise in coitus?
BLEGHADAS. Hold on, I gotta call Tommy Lee
Jones.
Hi Tommy Lee, it's me John Green. I'm gonna
need that magic wand you used in the film
Men in Black 'cause I need to un-remember
something. [tortoise in coitus] Oh God, Tommy
Lee it's happening again.
So Hank, I present to you the majestic, giant
tor- [tortoise in coitus] ahhhh come on!
Alright Hank, so there are a few things you
need to understand about tortoises in order
to understand their sexuality. One: Tortoises
often don't hit sexual maturity until they're
like 20 years old. Two: An average adult male
tortoise weighs 200 pounds more than females.
And number three: tortoises have a lot in
common with the male characters on the television
phenomenon Jersey Shore. They don't have jobs,
they're huge without being technically overweight,
and for both species the primary method of
flirting involves head-bobbing.
Okay, so whether the male tortoise is considered
hot is decided mostly by the length of his
neck. I mean you know what they say about
tortoises with longs necks.
So, the male tortoises will be hanging out
and they'll be like "Look, my neck is so long,"
and the other tortoise will be like "My neck
is even longer," and whoever has the longest
neck generally gets the most desirable mating
situations.
Okay, so you're a long-necked tortoise and
you start to approach your lady friend. Then
begins the head-bobbing. The male tortoise
walks up to the female tortoise and bobs his
head like crazy in an attempt to, I don't
know, look turtle sexy.
At this point one of a few things might happen.
It might be that your lady friend just allows
you to mount her. Now of course a lot of people
are wondering about the actual mechanics of
tortoise sex. This is pretty straight forward.
The underside of the male shell, which is
called the plastron, is conveniently enough
concave. So the shells actually fit pretty
well together.
Yeah, I don't blame you at all from walking
away from that, little turtle.
The male tortoise balances like a three-legged
stool on his hind feet and his tail and then,
you know, [tortoise in coitus] Ah not the
noise again.
Hank, you want to know the worst thing about
this noise? This noise [tortoise in coitus]
is the only noise tortoises ever make. Like,
occasionally they'll, like, make hissing sounds
but in terms of really utilizing their vocal
chords, just this. [tortoise in coitus]
So Hank, that's how it goes when everyone
is enthusiastic about mating, but sometimes
the lady tortoises say "You know, I don't
really want to have someone who weighs 200
pounds more than me hump me." In that situation
the male tortoise will walk around to the
front of the female and start biting her feet.
He does this because eventually she will retract
her feet into her shell thereby rendering
her immobile so he can run around and you
know.
You stay classy giant tortoise.
Once insemination occurs the female tortoises
lay their eggs in a shallow nest and eight
months later, baby tortoises! Who will grow
up alone in a terrifying world where this
passes for love.
Hank, I can't wait for your song on Wednesday;
on Friday we'll be learning about giant squids,
not of anger, but of love. By the way Nerdfighters,
both this giant squid of anger shirt designed
by Nerdfighter Vondell Swain and this DFTBA
shirt, which reminds everyone who looks at
your chest not to forget to be awesome, are
available now at DFTBA.com, link in the doobly
doo. They're in stock and ship immediately,
at least until we run out of them.
Also, please go to projectforawesome.com and
sign up for the Project for Awesome mailing
list. The mailing list is one of the main
ways we have of organizing so we can descend
upon videos about non-profits and bring them
to the world.
And yes, I know that my glasses are crooked.
My son is 10 months old. He is a glasses monster.
Please forgive me.
Hank, I'll see you on Wednesday.
By the way Hank, I'm not gonna lie, learning
all of this has dramatically affected my relationship
with the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles. I mean
seriously Donatello, I did not expect you
to be a biter of lady feet.